Hello and welcome to exercise three using multiple slots.
So in this exercise, we are going to be creating a bit more complicated definition file so
that we can imitate something that might be like a car or something like that.
But where you want to have multiple slots and the different AI would do different things in different slots.
Now to start with, I would like you to move to the third slide in the training eight.
That's exercise three multiple slots.
And you should see that we have a set up that looks a little bit like this.
Now if I was to simulate, we'd see that all the AI walk around and in the middle there is a bonfire with a guitar.
So what I'm looking to do here is have the characters sit around the bonfire and one of them to play the guitar.
Now if we look through what we have here, we have the BP bonfire itself that we're going to make into the smart object or character and the M underscore play guitar.
If we were to look at the montage for the play guitar.
Now the interesting bit that we have about this is we are using a specific bone here called the interaction.
And the way I'm going to animate that is I have put together this animation with the guitar on the interaction button.
And that means when the character comes in and picks it up, it will use the the transform of the interaction boat in order to know the location for the boat.
And this means that we can just pick it up and put it down and it will sync with the animation.
You'll also see that at the beginning here we have an a N toggle use object.
And all this is is an animation notifier where I open that up.
We do a couple of things here.
We receive the notifier and I'm getting the owner of the notifier say finding the smart object.
And I'm saving a couple of variables on the smart object.
A variable Boolean saying play guitar and a variable save of the skeleton mesh.
That's all I need in order to get this up and running.
It's relatively straightforward.
You can go in and look at it.
It's not the best example.
But what I want to concentrate on in this example is putting together a more complicated definition.
So let's do that now.
What I would like you to do is right hand click.
And again, we're going to come up to miscellaneous and we are looking for data asset.
Once we select data asset, I'm going to search for smart and you can see we have a smart object definition here.
I will select that and I'm going to call this smart object definition underscore bonfire.
And then double click to open this up.
Now to start off with we have no slots.
So we're going to want to add some slots in, but it's a little hard to place the slots down when we don't know what the object looks like.
Luckily, we have a preview settings up here.
So I'm going to come up to the preview settings and under the object actor class, I am going to search for BP underscore bonfire.
I'm going to select the bonfire.
And now we can see we have our guitar and our bonfire.
And this will help us to add in the different sockets.
Now the first socket I would like to add.
I want this one to be the one where we have the guitar player in it.
I'm going to drag this over to the right hand side.
And I already have played around with this and I reckon the offset needs to be about 190.
And I also want to rotate it.
880 degrees.
So it's facing back towards the center.
Now that's good so far.
Now next up.
It doesn't matter so much where these slots are.
And that's because we we don't have to line it up as long as it's on the floor.
It shouldn't make much difference.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to add in a few different slots.
And see they always appear in the middle.
I'm going to rotate them so that they face in.
So I'm actually just going to put them all in place first.
I'm not going to make it too even.
And I'm just going to grab all of these and rotate them so that they're facing the fire.
OK, so that's given us six slots here for people to be gathered around the fire.
Now they're all called none.
I'm going to jump on the first one.
I'm going to rename this to guitar.
Because this is the only one that we're going to do something slightly different with.
Now we need to set up the behavior.
So I'm going to come in here and I'm going to select the index.
I'm going to come down to gameplay behavior smart object.
And in the drop down, I'm just going to be looking for exercise three so that DBC underscore sitting down exercise three.
Now drop down again.
We have a default of sitting on the floor.
That's fine.
So as long as those are up, that's for our default.
So all of the slots are going to have that.
But in the guitar one, we want to override that.
So under the behavior definitions, I'm going to hit plus.
And I'm going to select the game pay behavior smart object definition.
Another drop down.
Again, I'm going to select game pay configuration sitting down.
I want the option to play guitar.
Okay, and with that done, we can now come in and open up our bonfire.
We need to add in our smart object.
And we need to set that to bonfire.
You look at the viewport.
We can see now that the guitar one is pointing towards the guitar and everything looks okay.
So if we come back into the level here, we select this.
We can actually see the spots.
And if I press simulate, you can now see that some of the characters sit around.
But the one that is in the slot with the guitar is going to start playing the guitar as soon as it's there.
And that brings us to the end of our final exercise video.
Hopefully you may get that all working.
Thank you very much.